let's start with news that is just
breaking today in the college bribery
scandal Lauri Lachlan is apparently
going to fight it out sorry about the
bad news Lauri are you fighting this to
the end the fight is on both Lori and
her husband have pled not guilty to the
charges connected to the widespread
college admissions cheating scandal
Lori's signature appears on the court
filings obtained by ET the couple have
waived their rights to appear in federal
court for the arraignment legal analyst
Rachel Stockman tells et why Lori's case
would be so tough to defend if it goes
to trial according to the prosecution
they have some pretty damning evidence
in the form of tapes recordings of Lori
so I think it's gonna be a very hard
case to fight in court if convicted Lori
faces a maximum prison sentence of 40
years a source close to the actress
tells ET when she heard that number
quote she broke down crime but her
husband feels they are not guilty they
were under the impression they might be
breaking rules but not laws I paid 500
grand to a women's crew coach to say my
daughter was good at rowing on SNL kate
mckinnon spooked what Lloyd's life
behind bars could look like you think
prison is hard I have done 68 hallmark
I'm gonna take your heart and I'm gonna
cut it funny Kate would say that because
Lori's Hallmark show when calls the
heart was just renewed for another
season but without Lori
[Music]
[Applause]